in addition uh to being a professor of
history and politics he's also the
author of several books
most recently churchill's trial winston
churchill and the salvation of free
government
his lecture topic is education and
politics
please welcome the 12th president of
hillsdale college dr larry pjarne
good morning
is this good
wow that shapiro i'm proud of
tim and doug and matt for organizing
this thing and if mr shapiro's remarks
cause a scandal i'll blame it all on
them
i've what he's a massive talent and i
was so afraid when andrew breitbart
died untimely that it would
wilt her away but no
and then i walked in the room and
discovered that he's 14 years old
and i'm i'm not talking down to him if
he's tempted to take it that way uh if
my own experience is any judge it won't
last
um and i want to say where oh i should
say he talked about the college campus
messages
and that stuff broke out in my campus
one time in my knowledge
in my own class and one of my students a
boy from arkansas said
dr arne have you ever been accused of a
micro aggression
i looked at him richard was his name is
his name and i said
not micro
that's not our style
and uh i have a thought from ayan i'm
very taken with this conference i hope
you are too um i adore that woman and uh
you can watch her i've known her a long
time now and you can watch her think and
learn and
and she introduced a fundamental
distinction last night
and it's like the distinctions that are
in the classic authors between kinds of
regimes and this distinction was between
medina and me and mecca the to the fa
the mecca and medina the phases she says
of muhammad's career
and then she we left a question hanging
which is how do you tell
because there's lots of good people who
are muslims who are in the country how
do you tell
and i went away thinking about that and
i've thought of something
i think you can look at how the women
dress
because
you know i'm married to a woman and
i like women
and
i like my wife a lot right and one of
the things about her is she's
interesting to talk to
she's a free human being
and so what kind of culture
shrouds them
and confines them and constrains them
and that's a weakness
so i think we should watch for that i
think it's hard to get that to happen i
think a lot of them don't like it
i know the story of
you probably know that douglas macarthur
effectively wrote the constitution that
governs japan today
and he did it in 1945-46
it became possible because we had
leveled the country
and they would come to him he was the
governor general and they would give him
a draft of the constitution in their by
accounts in in for example in uh william
manchester's biography of him
that this happened 30 or 40 different
conferences where they'd bring him and
they said well you could change this so
basically he was rewriting the whole
thing and the sticking point
was the women
he thought the women ought to vote
and their arguments that took a long
time and their arguments were well they
don't want to vote they won't vote
and then they had their first election i
think in 1947
and the women came out in droves
so i just mentioned that that's
something to think about right i think
that's a weakness of those regimes one
of the forms of despotism they practice
that probably make them vulnerable
and i think we should talk about that a
lot more
so my topic is education and politics
ben shapiro's topic was politics on the
campus and i'm going to talk about how
those politics have remade our country
and are now in turn it's a cycle
remaking
the campus
but it started in the campus
and the connection between education and
politics is fundamental
in the classical time
in the time of our founding and now
just in different ways
in in classical times what what do we
think what do they think what do they
teach us
it's very beautiful what they teach us
it's the greatest single thing to study
i think there is it's what the founders
of our country studied
and what they teach us is
good people
can't be good if they don't have good
laws
and good laws can only be made by good
people
so at the end of aristotle's ethics
which is the first book of ethics in my
mind the greatest one that i've ever
read
it's about how you get your own soul
into a condition
so that you can live a fully human life
so you can be fully what a human being
is
and it ends with him saying after it
culminates in book 10 of the ethics
there are 10 books they're called or
chapters big chapters
at the end it culminates in the life of
contemplation shared in the individual
soul or most sublimely among a few
friends
and that's not a political thing exactly
it's beyond that
but then
it turns right at the end and it
says you can't build your
character and mind and therefore soul
to a place to enjoy that
except with good laws
and so it points to aristotle's politics
the first real book of political science
ever written and one of the best
and at the end of the politics he says
and the politics is about how you get
good laws and what they are in the
various kinds of laws and comparing them
various kinds of regimes and comparing
them
and he says at the end of that
good laws come from good people
so do you see the problem
what if both the law and the people is
bad
it's a problem
we must not let that happen of course
but they will tend to come into
conformity with each other over time
now these thoughts and it just means
that education is a central activity
it is what we say to the future
if you work in a college here's what you
learn
the thing that's most interesting to
them
is the thing are the things that
everybody needs to know
like you can teach them welding and some
you know i used to weld when i was in
high school at every kind of job i fancy
i was a pretty good well
better waiter
okay college president
uh
but
that's interesting right but they don't
know when they're 18 years old if
they're going to be welders or doctors
or lawyers
and so it's no use teaching them civil
torts and contracts and
tax law
they can get started on that stuff but
what do they need to know
they need to know
what am i
how do i be a good one of those
and so the founders knowing that
passed the first law regarding education
national law in american history in the
northwest ordinance
and article three it's a very
fundamental piece of legislation is
actually the first time a free
government ever grew
and it invented a novel way to grow
no colonies
equal states coming in when they get
enough people self-government soon
it's very beautiful
but article three
lays out what it what what had been
begun to happen in a land ordinance two
years earlier
that
one part of the public land and only one
36th of the western land and think what
a resource that is
it's america
and
at the time that they're writing this
nobody had ever seen the other end of it
and come back to tell the tale
but they start with the northwest
territory where michigan is
and they say 136
you know 35 36 of that vast land out
there will be sold into private hands as
rapidly as possible
to serve the public good people owning
things using them working with them
living their lives
136 was reserved to
education
on this principle
religion morality and knowledge being
necessary to good government and the
happiness of mankind
schools and the means of education shall
ever be encouraged
think about that sentence
it's beautiful
but also it's profound
what do you need to be happy and live
well
it mentions both
morality religion and knowledge is a
personal good
and as a civic good
and they go together
this profundity of relationship
i mean it
you just can't understand how important
it is
raise up the child in the way that he
should go says the bible
the word education comes from a latin
word that means lead forth
which way is fourth
that's a value statement right this is
the way forward
and this is how we preserve
everything good if we do that
so the new way which was invented in
america in the 19th century and in
europe a bit earlier
has remade the country but it begins in
and for education
the people who started the revolution
that bernie sanders is attempting to
advance
and about him i read i happily don't
know that much about
bernie sanders and hope not to
but i've been learning more and i read
that
he talks about his poverty and he never
had a cent and he's a graduate of the
university of chicago
a poor
boy
but he got his first job to pay to get a
paycheck when he was 30 years old
and he got it from a government agency
and apparently i read i don't know and i
as i say i do not put myself forward as
an expert on bernie sanders but i read
that all of his paychecks have come from
such places
where did that start
well
the founders of the progressive movement
in america are a few people and almost
all of them academics
you can read several of them especially
woodrow wilson and john dewey and frank
good now
in our constitution reader which you
know hundreds of thousands of people
have read now
but which every student at hillsdale
college reads and i want to mention a
point there about diversity right
because
if you read the great books
and the big events in history
you're going to read a bunch of stuff
that doesn't all say the same thing
and so if you discipline yourself to
understand those things you involve
yourself in a great argument that has
operated at the peaks of human society
for two thousand years or more
and so
we read those guys right and what do
they say and you can read them in our
constitution reader which is online if
you want to read it
or buy it
and what do they say
well there's a revolution they say
everything is different now
because what has happened is
we have come to understand
that our
uh
consciousness
a new word right
it sort of means our mental
climate
not weather changing all the time sort
of background big
furniture in our mind the weather the
climate in our mind and you know the
climate is of course warming
but um
except not fast enough in michigan
that that is set
by the framework in which we live
but something has changed we live in an
economic
socioeconomic milieu
by the way don't you notice
when you start talking about these guys
you have to start using a bunch of
stupid sounding words
because like old words like knowledge
and wisdom and virtue and good and
philosophy right those are terribly hard
words to define
but the ability to define them which
takes years is a great blessing to the
soul and everybody has some rough idea
what those words mean
to refine that idea is to become an
educated person
that's why i like to
you know
just
i work this trick ten times a week when
i'm in
town
what are you gonna major in and they
name it and i say what's that
they never know
you know
they're 19 years old right
my favorite is politics of course i'm
gonna i'm gonna study politics and i'll
say what's that and they always say well
it's governing
and i'll say like i do here
and they'll say yes and then i'll show
them the first paragraph of aerosols
politics which says that it's a
different kind of rule in politics
and then they'll see so you
put that to them and i'll say so
it's governing right
but what kind
so it's a mess right takes forever
and everything is like that right
but then you get into this new stuff and
we're just making up a whole new
vocabulary of course
to account
for a new understanding of nature
which understanding means that there
really isn't any nature
there's just nature is something in fact
it's change
everything is change and we are formed
by this change
so you can read woodrow wilson and john
dewey both writing in our constitution
reader that
the people who wrote the declaration of
independence were just speaking for
their time
they were victims of their it was good
that they did that right
but now we know better than that they
use the word obsolete in regards to the
declaration of independence which
remember the time perspective of the
declaration of independence is extremely
radical
when in the course of human events
in the old time right
the laws of nature and of nature's god
and just think
once you start taking that talking like
that
it is a breathtaking
revolutionary achievement because the
declaration of independence
is resigned
to a time period
and it doesn't really it can't mean that
it was good for its time
because its claim is it's good for every
time and if it's wrong now it must have
been wrong back then too
and that's what they really think
now it changes the academic task big
time once you think that way
because
uh frank goodnow who's my favorite
example and i owe to andre pestrito that
i even know who that guy is
rj has more patience than i have with
reading idiots
and uh
but very influential idiots you know and
so he's in our reader and i had not ever
read anything by him until i taught our
constitution course i knew about him and
i knew fair amount about woodrow wilson
and dewey but this guy is especially
good right he's an academic guy and he
writes in a passage in our constitution
reader we teachers academics take
ourselves too seriously sometimes
because we think
that we are
forming the student
helping them to grow and learn but
really
what they're going to think in the
future
is going to be a product of the economic
times that develop in the future
think what a gloomy thing that is to say
you know i'm privileged
i have students lots lots and you know
i've been there a long time around some
of them are grown-ups and they're big
deals
and they're starting to tell me what to
do
you know the way you do with your dad
you know and your dad thinks it's funny
at first
uh
and a lot of them are you know really
important people
big places in congress
supreme court clerks now big time
lawyers right
but why
does it matter to them to tell me what
to do
i'm their teacher
and you know they don't really think
they can tell me what to do one of their
favorite thing i overheard to them
saying it the other day in washington
because they were beating me up about
something
and one was a very senior guy on the
staff of the majority leader in the
congress
and i said
i said okay
you're gonna stand here and tell me all
this right now
and he turned to a friend and he said
well he's still not a tame lion is he
there's just no estimating how much i
value those people
and our relationship and they
value it deeply but what good good now
is saying is it doesn't matter
you see and you see another thing
it shifts the focus away
from the knowledge that the human soul
can apprehend
to the work that the human soul can do
upon the society and the events in it
because if what is controlling us is all
these circumstances
what if we could control the
circumstance
what if we could make the economy what
if we could create our own world what if
we could create our own nature in the
ways that ben shapiro mentioned
then at last we could be in control you
see and then we could even understand
because these things that are
influencing us now at last we are
influencing them
and that is the birth of the modern
social sciences
and what and that is the the birth of
the bureaucratic project which is really
simple to understand it is just the idea
that highly trained people in touch with
science and engaged in a kind of
scientific project like in a research
laboratory
can make prescriptions in detail for the
operation of the entire society
which prescriptions have to be of course
commands to people to what they will do
it's it's crazy
you know like the boy i'm talking about
who's a big wheel in the congress his
name will dunham
and he was an english major
and you know he has said on a video that
we show sometimes when we want to pump
me up a bunch
that
i'm the one who turned him into what he
is right
but i just know infinitely better than
that
because there was a whole bunch of
people in that class i remember it very
distinctly and each of them had his
gifts right
and will had very particular gifts
and i gave them and you know he just you
say something
and what he repeats back to you
is better
he's thinking right
i gave him a blue book exam you know
what those are you know they got to
write these blue books and they're ugly
and everybody hates them
and
teachers
hate
to give them and read them and students
hate to write them
the process of education is a process of
mutual torture
and so i read will's blue book exam one
time and it was just great a bunch of
essays right and then i turned to the
last page in it it gone all the way to
the last page which when you look at
them you open them and look at the last
page look to the last page to see how
long it is and when it's really long
you've grown
you know
and what was on the last page was a
picture he had drawn
and it was a map of my mind
and the top or most parts of my mind
were the most important things i think
and it sort of worked its way down right
the map is accurate i still still have
it you know
and see
i didn't do that
will did that
and i don't think the economic
circumstances and the social milieu of
will did that
i think the divine spark in his soul did
that see
that's wiped out that's gone now
and so what we teach them to do now in
the university is we turn them into an
engineering project
and
one element of it but it's much the
weaker element is the element of
self-definition
you can have your values can be whatever
you please them to be
but that doesn't last because it's
ignoble and because it doesn't make
sense given the kind of thing we are
which they still have some contact with
and so what it really turns into is you
have to remake the society
ben shapiro mentioned you know you get
up in the morning and you decide that
you're going to be one of the several
other genders
we have eight dormitories at health
college and we divide the dormitories by
sex
eight is not enough
it's a poser we're trying to figure out
you know
but um
but
it turns into this it's not that you can
be whatever you want to be
tomorrow morning
that becomes a side issue
you can make everybody else recognize
that
you can remake all of our social
relations
that's
breathtaking
and despotic because just think the
emphasis
goes away
from you realizing
something worthy eternal
universal
beautiful
that it is your particular spark being a
human to be able to do and the
fulfillment of your ultimate capacities
now two
you're working on things to change them
but the things that you're working on
are people
because we're not regulating the
environment
we're regulating people
we're not regulating
anything bernie sanders
is not going to regulate
money or taxes
he's going to regulate people
and he's going to do that with a view to
altering what they are
now it comes back
to the college to the university oh i
should mention this first
i just said there are these pr i'll
rehearse three profound kinds of
connections actually they're just two
between education and politics the
classical view and the view at the time
of the founding of america which are the
same and this new view which is that the
university and its scientists
become a force to remake the society
john dewey in 1916 general reporter in
1916
wrote the document that founded the
teachers union for colleges
by which we've been blacklisted for 25
years
um
yeah
i didn't do it happened before i came
whatever it was
but uh but
he says that the purposes of the college
are changed now
first of all teaching and research are
divided which inherently they very much
are not
you know the very large number of things
that i've learned in the classroom that
are fundamental to stuff that i knew a
great deal about a long time before i
ever became a teacher
the depth that i know them with
they're huge i've written three books i
couldn't have written any of them if i
hadn't been teaching that stuff
because you just learn so much when you
do it
while they do with them that's what
happens in a classroom it's it's by the
way it's gorgeous it's just so much fun
and it is a little aggressive i
confess but going along with this
enterprise to remake the society there's
this immediate connection between
politics and education now
because education
is one of the most potent electoral
political forces in the land
and just think constitutional government
does not generate a lot of employees in
the government
and bureaucratic government does
generate a lot of employees in fact
under constitutional government
private according to tocqueville in the
1830s private citizens do most of it
they don't you know
the the
our state representative right now is a
man named lloyd hauser who's a car
dealer in town and his daddy was on the
board of the college and they're an old
distinguished family and
my boy will dunham that i've been
mentioned is married to one of the lloyd
howser girls
got her pregnant again
and uh and um
eric the state rep told me i met her
daddy one time right after i was hired
president because he died a few years
later but i was taken because he was a
man of great dignity i had to meet him
before he died
and eric told me that his father said
that back in the 60s when he was the
mayor of hillsdale
hillsdale had five employees
three cops and two secretaries
right now it's the same size town now
we're not vibrant with growth up in
michigan
it has a hundred employees now
you see
multiplied times 30. that's about what's
happened
so now how many people work in education
there are
in public education in america as of
2013
there are 3.1
million teachers
and there are 3.1 million administrators
and support staff
the number
uh in 50 years according to the friedman
foundation
the number of students
in 50 from 1950 till 2009 59 years
has grown 96 percent
the number of teachers has grown 252
percent
and the number of administrators and
other staff has grown 702 percent
now
i'll compare with our barney charter
schools you know about that
so there's these 13 charter schools
right and
and it's just like a classroom it's a
it's a in a common partnership
enterprise of mutual torture
uh we pay for what we do we don't get
any money from them and we've got
five full-time employees working on this
now and eventually it'll be seven
and a bunch of our faculty help and we
give them a curriculum and we train
their teachers and we help them hire
their headmaster and we accredit them
every year
and they come to the campus 250 teachers
last last year
and they learn
with each other and with our faculty you
know who know a lot of stuff
they're very serious people
and they've got 30 years of knowledge
and they've got superb minds
so it's that's our part right their part
is
they have to do what we say if they want
to continue to use our name they can
stop any day they want to none has
they have fantastic results right all of
the ones that are two years old or older
they take the state standardized test
a central bureaucratic
thing
to try to make every kid in america
learn the same thing
no child left behind
somebody from the bush administration
came to see
somewhere i think the hillsdale but
somewhere john cevini i remember were at
the table and he said that bush was
going to do a lot in education as he had
done in texas george w bush and i knew
what he'd done texas i didn't like it
and he said we're going to do the no
child left behind act and we'd like your
help
and i said well i don't really know what
it is i said dumb title
and he said
it's a great title
why not every child no child should be
left behind i said sir
you ever been in the
classroom i mean 15 minutes
somebody's always getting left behind
it's just how it is you know you can't
stop it
and
it's what ben said right people are
different
so
we don't we we take those tests we have
to right
in florida there's a big prosecution of
many people in public education and
they're being prosecuted for giving the
kids the answers
because they get promoted and they get
money if the kids do well on the test
and public schools all over america take
february and march and they cram for
those tests
right big standardized whacking things
right in our charter schools in our
hillsdale academy i see calvert sitting
back there
we take them
have two
i think the academy doesn't it takes
some other stuff
but
um the preparation is only this it
doesn't affect the curriculum at all the
announcement the night before us
tomorrow we're going to take a test
all of those schools are ranked at the
highest possible level in the top tier
in every state seven or eight different
states now right
and what's the administrative burden in
those schools
so we got six divided by thirteen
so there's
what is that a third of a third of one
for each one
a little more than half a little more
almost half wanted for each one
and then
the austin charter school i know in
detail because
the greatest young academic in america
today runs it
my daughter
and
so i know all about that place she
doesn't call us she's in the second year
now she's not having many crises
but uh i know who works in there because
i've been in there right and so it's her
and she teaches and there's assistant
headmaster who teaches full-time
and then there's three
people who work in the office so we're
up to five and there's a custodian
i think that's the whole bunch
and so add in then my the hillsdale
college half a person who constitutes an
administrator
i think you've got six and a half
and you've got forty teachers
so the ratio is one or one point one to
one administrators to teachers in the
public schools and in this
it's
one two
about seven
what's that about
what are those administrators doing why
is it so expensive
see there's an army of people
who are governing and reinventing and
regulating education and they numbered
the same or more than the teachers
now think about what those people are
like
because
as we all know
people who work for the government don't
have any interest of their own
you know because of course and that by
the way you should read pastrito i
haven't see back sitting back there
about this because he writes about this
they actually think that these
these
the people who work in the government of
whom by the way they're 21 civil
21 million civilian employees
state local and federal in the
government of the united states today
and they're not
i mean you know i realize that they're
strictly nonpartisan and only care for
her you know but
14 of the top 25 donators in politics
today
are public employee unions
and the biggest one is the teachers
union
and it's two and a half times the next
biggest one
it's an army of people
and what do they want i think a lot of
the teachers joined the union because
they got all these bureaucrats one
telling them what to do and they want
some protection
and they don't quite see
that the union is sustaining and growing
the bureaucracy
it's like just like the kids in the bad
schools right
they're like captives
you know what i said about that muslim
women probably don't like it and it's a
source of weakness in people who are
enemies and they're not just to their
own citizens
i think there's something like that
laden in education too
my dad was a school teacher
he said he found his happiness being a
school teacher
my daughter is a school teacher she says
she found her happiness doing that right
i'm a school teacher it's a noble and
fine profession
wouldn't there be a political program to
liberate those people
let them do what they do
so now this bureaucracy
which began
in the academic world
and has remade the government has become
especially when it stems from the
schools
into a major electoral political force
and it has direct interest in the size
and remunerate remuneration of people
who work in the
in the government
and since this is a representative
government
that means there's this big old circle
of society and there's a small circle of
government in it and all the sovereignty
the ultimate authority is out here among
us and all the power to act is in there
in the government
if the government gets close to half the
size of the country the direct
expenditure is about 40 percent of the
gdp now
and then there's the regulatory
expenditure which is very powerful and
might make up another 15 it's harder to
count
then all of a sudden you could have
a government
that might overwhelm the society that is
supposed to be electing it
and that started in education and it's
working its way back into it now again
so in this latest phase i don't know if
it's the last phase
all of a sudden we have these cry
bullies
and what they are is
18 19 20 and 21 year olds
often in very elite places
where they are enjoying massive
privileges
and these elite places especially are
all very old
and they have been very excellent and
the demand is that they abandon what
they were built to do and apologize for
everything up to now and proceed in
future along lines that are dictated in
the tone of harsh commands
and as ben shapiro said people are being
fired and being humiliated and it's
astonishing to me how many of those
people
participate in their own humiliation
the president
one of the colleges over in claremont
where i got a lot of my
education
was apparently carrying on negotiations
with these people for some months
and when the thing in
missouri broke
they
they
made vocal
their public demands although apparently
he was already giving way on them in
private and so his reaction to that when
the storm hit his campus was he
organized a sit-in in his own office
made a public fact to that gave them
everything they want and then presented
it to the college
where some of my friends teach
did pass the faculty
board is apparently putting up with it
but think what that means right so i'll
give you just one example
uh
at amherst college you know what that is
right
back in massachusetts very distinguished
always in the top five among liberal
arts colleges
students are demanding that the
president
biddy martin
issue an apology to marginalized
individuals
who have been the victims of our
institutional legacy
of white supremacy colonialism
anti-black racism
you're going to like this list and i
don't know what it all means
anti-latinx with an ex racism
anti-native american racism anti-native
indigenous racism that's something else
anti-asian racism anti-middle eastern
racism heterosexism
psy sexism
ben shapiro told you what that was and
i'm not sure he's right but i don't know
what i think it is maybe it's
it's these are speculative sciences
we're engaged in right
what i think it is
is that i look at one of you and assume
that you're a male or a female and use
those pronouns for you
whereas you don't think that's what you
are or anyway i'm making an assumption
that is a microaggression
i think it's that
xenophobia that's an ancient greek word
anti-semitism ableism mental health
stigma and classism
among other things
you know that dang amherst is a bad
place
and for a long time
so what do we actually know about ra
you know i don't know anything about a
race amherst except it's elite my friend
had the arc is taught most of his career
there until he retired lately
and calvin coolidge went there
and calvin coolidge wrote an
autobiography
and it contains something i'm going to
read to you
it's about a professor at amherst
named charles garman
whom he remembers was deep reverence
and he says that you had to take
garmin's course for two or four
semesters i'm forgetting which right now
and he says that the first thing the
first part of it was you had to learn
what it was to prove something
which
if you think about it for a minute is
hard to do
you have to learn to reason you have to
learn to use your mind and that's a hard
kind of study we're about to implement
our course in rhetoric and logic and
it's going to be pure torture it's why
the provost back there has recommended
it he said we need to add one more
course to the core
and i think his descriptive adjectives
were
ugly
unpleasant
grueling he used all kinds of words like
that and of course everybody in the room
said okay good let's do that
but you have to learn how to reason
right you have to learn how to not make
mistakes
and that's hard and it gets right inside
you right you've got to really give
yourself to something like that any high
learning but that's a particularly tough
one
and coolidge says he did that
and then he gets to the conclusions he
learned from this guy garmin he says our
investigation revealed that man is
endowed with reason
that the human mind has the power to
weigh evidence to distinguish right and
wrong and to know the truth
this i would say was the central theme
of his philosophy
we looked upon garmin as a man who
walked with god
in the fatherhood of god
we learned of the brotherhood of man
every reaction in the universe was a
manifestation of his presence
it sets man off as in a separate kingdom
from all the other creatures in the
universe and makes him a true son of god
and a partaker of divine nature
this is the warrant for his freedom and
the demonstration of his equality
would you like to go study with charles
garman
i would
and did you know that calvin coolidge
is the man who gave the as president
the speech on the 150th anniversary of
the declaration of independence
you know how it ends
we live in an age
of abounding science and material
progress
but the things of the spirit come first
if all men are created equal that is
final
if they are endowed by the creator with
inalienable rights that is final
you see
there's a thing that makes us what we
are and it makes us all what we are
and to regard any human being
as a being you can abuse
or
put a bridle on like you can any horse
is an offense against that human being
that's what they were teaching at
amherst by their most distinguished and
foremost professor
early in the 20th century when calvin
coolidge went there
calvin coolidge gave a speech at howard
university
historically by college you know
and it's about the equal rights of
everyone of all colors
and these kids at amherst
are slandering that
and destroying the legacy of that
and they've got no idea it even exists
and of course that implies
because this stuff
the cycle is now known right
in principle it's present in the classic
works in principle it's present in the
founding and now it's actual among us
today
what happens in the classroom makes its
way into the society and what happens to
society back into the classroom
if these people graduate and they're in
the best places
and they become our rulers
what's it going to be like when the laws
reflect these ideas
one sees
the dark hand of despotism stretching
out
and it will be
violent and ugly
but i'll close with this it won't be
and i'll tell you why
because these doctrines these kids are
being taught lead nowhere good
and they are so awful
compared to the lovely things that can
be learned in a college
you know our kids are smart real smart
and they're very hard-working and what
is the story as they go through
they grow
both in assertiveness and in humility
because to
you have to be bold and you have to push
to attempt to understand the most
beautiful things
but you also have to admit that you
don't know and you have to have a
reverence for them
and it becomes a satisfying life that
settles into one and guides it until it
dies
up to the next world
this doesn't produce that
this produces
resentment and bitterness and friction
it is ugly
and it cannot sustain
and then i'll just say these two things
the way out is plain
and we stand for that and because all of
this will engulf us if it engulfs the
society
we may get a chance to prove that we'll
stand that to the last stand
we will be praying for god to give us
the strength
so far we've found it
thank you
thank you president aaron we now have
time uh for some questions we have two
microphones uh please wait for the
microphone and uh
anybody wanna say anything
dr arm
hi john
good to see you good to see you
i've had a question that's bothered me
quite a while and it relates to your
relationship with
politics and teachings
in a humble sense
do you ever have a problem
in differentiating between the
human soul
and your conscience
well it occurs to me as a professor and
teacher
and i'm very careful when i walk that
line and i'm wondering whether or not
that is shared by the imminent person in
your position
yeah okay
so my soul is actually right over here
and my conscience is
down here a little lower now it so i can
only give you the account of a great man
great mind about that
so the human soul is a very
it's unique there's anything else like
it that we see because it's attached to
a body
the human soul is an is a
human being is an integrity of mind and
body it's not a mind and a body or a
mind or a body it's both
and so
aristotle imagines then that the soul
must have certain attributes for it to
perform the way it seems to perform
it
it must be to start with immaterial
it can't be in any place
it isn't the brain
it's connected to the body
it doesn't function that we can see when
the body dies
but
why does it have to be like that because
it can reason
and what reason means is that
i know that you are a man and i know
that i am a man and i know that
you know there's a woman and there's a
woman and yet they're different
so we recognize essences of things
which are never the same thing as the
particular thing in front of you
so how does it do that he says well it
has to be immaterial
but then it has to be connected to the
body
because it feels passions and needs and
wants and it has to to survive
pleasures and pains the first obstacles
to the practice of the character the
doing virtues are pleasure and pain
and and there's information in pleasure
and pain and you need that information
but the right disposition toward them is
crucial and the right disposition toward
pain is courage and the right
disposition toward pleasure is
moderation
and as you learn those things you become
freer
and better able to think among other
things
so this connection to the body is
profound now what about this question of
the conscience
which i think means
the propensity to seek the good
now
every living being
according to aristotle
seeks its
good dogs like to be like dogs and
horses like to be like horses and plants
like to grow up and find a space to be
what they're supposed to be
that's how he
describes it
but we're different because we are
agents in this
and you can see because we have volition
that is to say we can choose things and
that too is born in this capacity to
recognize common nouns which is what
reason is
you see
for me to treat you rightly
only becomes a question after i know
what kind of thing you are
right
like
millie our boxer is a liar and a thief
but she doesn't you know she doesn't
really know that she's lying or else
we'd have to put her down
but
our children
you know when they were growing up
they could be ashamed
still are all of us can right because
you're not supposed to treat people like
that you're not supposed to take their
stuff
but you can put a saddle on a horse and
ride it around and that's okay you just
can't do it to a person
you see so these common nouns give rise
to our sense of morality as well as our
ability to communicate
now
if all beings seek to be what they are
and the good is just each thing being
what it's supposed to be
right then then
then and we're agents in that
that is to say we can choose not to
you know like we we human beings have a
very complicated way of reproducing
ourselves and it takes a long time
hillsdale college parents you know
these kids are 20 years old and if they
were some other kind of creature they
wouldn't know what the who the kids are
right
but they're still the center of their
lives and yet we don't have to have
children
there'll be nobody to take care of when
we get old if we don't but they're mine
we don't have to and we can have them
and run off from them or abuse them if
we want to
but the point is
if we do that
unless we're insane which is rare
we know it's wrong
so the point is the conscience is just
an element of a volitional soul seeking
the good
as i understand it
how's that
i'd like to ask this question
i see the economic problem
for young people
after getting an education
their debt
economically speaking
is quite an interesting
phenomenon
and i wonder
whether
that is going to
sometime
really
affect
education
as a whole
could you speak to that issue and
how
how difficult it is
after getting out of college and then
having a debt of 100 000 fifty thousand
whatever the case may be
maybe those are even small figures i
don't know
could you speak to that please
yeah uh so
there's a i think it's a trillion
dollars now that's in student debt and
the default rates are very high
and to some extent the default rates are
encouraged
uh our default rate at hillsdale college
for 25 years is one percent
been steady for a long time
that means almost all of them pay the
money back and we have a limit on how
much they can borrow uh you know we try
to put together we're in the success
business at hillsdale college if they
come we want them to suffer and almost
die
but we also want them to succeed
and then get out and have great lives
so we try to put
the system together so that it works for
them as for us
and of course they don't pay for most of
it you do thank you very much
but yeah so
i what i think is uh
college has
always been expensive
there's never been a college of
inequality that
made its living off the fees the
students pay
and there's always been borrowing
associated with it it seems to be a lot
higher now
but i also think that there's way too
many people going to college
and
here's what i mean by that
training
learning practical things even elevated
practical things everybody needs to do
that and most everybody can
but this
this rarefied thing you know think of
all that complicated stuff i was just
talking about right
i'm surrounded by 18 to 21 year olds who
just love to talk about that stuff and
that's really weird
and it's not of any immediate practical
use
except it's the most fundamental
practical thing to teach you how to live
your life
well it used to be that a much smaller
percentage of people
did that
but now the goal is everybody should do
that and so we're changing what college
is
big time
so
if you want to learn to be an accountant
you know we we have a really great
accounting program and we're nationally
ranked in the cpa exams you know in the
top five somewhere i think of a third
last time
but
that that's a hard subject and that's
something you do in college
but you know i i was once asked to
by a rich man to get involved with the
oregon institute of technology
and about a third of their students were
studying engineering
and about two-thirds of their students
were learning to be dental assistants
i don't know if that's an economical way
to do that
maybe they should just go to
you know trade school
so i think that's part of the problem
and then
i i do know that the government
if you take their money they require you
to spend a lot of money
things that you might not choose to
accept that they require it
so that makes it more expensive
and then
i know that there's a conflict of
infancy you're not talking to the
world's leading expert on government
funding of colleges
because
it's real hard to understand
and if i was doing it i would have to
come to understand it
but i don't
so
this is true
uh how much you get from the government
there's a form we use the form it's
called the free application for federal
financial aid fafsa federal student aid
and you fill out this form and there's a
number on the form and i think it's your
adjusted gross income but i confess i
don't really remember
and then a bunch of deductions come and
then there's a bottom number
and one of the deductions is need factor
at the college
how much is their tuition room and board
and and
however the
the lower the bottom number
the more the student can get
but the money really comes straight to
the college
and the need factor i'm told
is determined and see i i'm i keep
repeating i don't really know why would
i find that out but
the need factor
is set by the number that the board
votes for tuition at the may meeting
whatever the number is
and so it doesn't matter if anybody pays
it
if that number is real high
then
the students are eligible more for more
aid and the college gets that money
and i am told that the federal
government is paying full freight
which most don't in hillsdale college or
anywhere now
so that means that then
most of the aid is loans
and that means they're buying
loans i mean they're paying
inflated numbers
like that so i think that's going on
here
and i think above all the distortions
are just so great
above all bigger than that debt question
is this question
since i have learned
that the student has to do most of the
learning
which is a enormous vindication by the
way of their freedom and their potential
it's a very fundamental thing that i've
learned in my life because i came to
this college didn't didn't really come
to be a teacher but i always have and do
every term
and i found it a profound experience
they
do it
and if they're bored or tired or
inactive
they're not learning and there's nothing
you can do about that
and that means college should be a place
for people who really want to go
and a high college has got to be a place
where you're longing to know this thing
and this thing is a very ultimate thing
and i'm going to take years
at the budding moment of my life and i'm
going to absorb this and carry it with
me the rest of life and there's no
financial inducement that can make
somebody really want to do that
and that's why i think the solution to
the problem of college cannot be just
continuously pouring more money into it
does that help
yeah
we have time for one last question
would you please address the
problem that hilton is going to have
when college education becomes free
and you're going to feel pressure to
take government money to
to a
handle of tuition for your kids that
come to hillsdale will you address that
question yeah well
um
you heard that
that's george messenger a man of science
and accomplishment
so first of all i don't know that that's
going to happen and pray that it won't
for the reason i just said
the imminent the future though imminent
is obscure said churchill
but our plan because remember the amount
of money that our competitors our
typical hillsdale competitor we're told
by our auditors
because you know we don't see the books
of other colleges we just see our own i
can tell you about our own
but uh our auditors put other similarly
sized liberal arts colleges that they
audit in a basket and compare them to us
for our board every year i i thought of
that
once they just mentioned one comparison
i said gosh you should make that
systematic
so what we think is they're getting
somewhere between well they're certainly
getting more than a third of what they
call student revenues from the
government
but we think they're getting totals
somewhere between 30 and 40 of total
revenues from the government so first of
all
wow
that's millions of bucks right
and so we can have that now
and why don't we do it
we're just stubborn as hell
um and we don't want to sign that paper
because they own you after that more
than they're coming to own us now
so the plan will just have to be
just like
it is now
we have to work hard by controlling our
cost and raising support
to be able to afford to operate when
everybody else has got all their money
from the government if that happens
i have a little
i have a system for keeping up with
stuff and
my particular system
has levels of things some of them i'm
working on right now and some of my
review once a week and some of them once
a month and i do it like that
and uh
one of the
monthly one is a question what if
tuition disappears
and you know it is
harder to collect tuition than it was
five years ago right now
because you know first of all our
standards are rising right so if you
come to hillsdale college somebody else
is offering you money
and uh and so
you know and people pay to come to our
college and we have a lot of
applications in a waitlist but the yield
of the tuition is not really going up
so
yeah that's a long-term thing and
in one way hillsdale college is 172
years old this year i think
i always get my numbers wrong when i do
that it's in its 172nd year is the right
way to say it
and it's never been financially stronger
than it is right now
but because of my job and because i love
the college and and think with pride of
its beginnings so long ago connected to
abraham lincoln
i would hate for it to be
for it to decline
anywhere inside of me
i don't want to see that
so we think about the future a lot
and i can just tell you what the tools
to cope with it would be
it's just as they say
watch your cost raise money be careful
and we do that all the time
uh
i'll also add that i know because i
understand these things that
i described at the beginning about the
connection between education and
politics if the country is overcome by
these things the college will be
overcome too
and then what do we do right well what
we do is
you know i i just think we have to try
to do this and i appreciate your help
and i ask you to understand this
i think we have to think like winston
churchill in 1940.
i think we have to think like abraham
lincoln in 1861 to 1865
we don't know how it's all going to come
out
we just are in control of what we do
and we have to get ready to make a stand
wouldn't it be shameful
if our country was beaten down by these
awful trends that have come in rebellion
against its meaning
and nobody intelligently or bravely
protested about it
and even in defeat to do that is a very
high station in fact especially in
defeat
so we try to gird ourselves up
thanks